The Suprising Cost of the NIke Logo
The creator of one of the most well-known
logos in history, the Nike “swoosh” logo,
was originally only paid $35 for it.
The woman is Carolyn Davidson.
At the time she created the now world famous
logo, Davidson was a student at Portland State
University where one of the co-founders of
Nike, Phil Knight, was teaching as an assistant
professor in accounting.
On the side, Knight ran a business called
Blue Ribbon Sports, the precursor to Nike.
(Blue Ribbon Sports primarily was a distributor
of Onitsuka Tiger shoes from Japan.)
It was simply by chance that Davidson met
Knight at all.
She was in the middle of a conversation with
a fellow student in the graphics design department
explaining that she didn’t have enough money
to take an oil painting class.
Knight overheard and later approached her
and asked her if she’d be interested in
doing some graphics work for his business,
offering her $2 an hour for the gig (about
$14 per hour today).
Davidson accepted and began doing various
freelance jobs for Blue Ribbon Sports, mostly
making charts and things of this nature.
A few years later, Knight decided it was time
to take his business to the next level, moving
away from being just a U.S. distributor of
Japanese running shoes and, rather, producing
and selling his own shoe lines.
Thus, in 1971, Knight asked Davidson to design
a “stripe”, which was the slang term at
the time for a logo for a shoe.
He further instructed her that he wanted it
to give the impression of motion.
Knight was particularly fond of the Adidas
logo, and though he said it couldn’t look
too similar to that, he was apparently enamored
by it.
As Davidson said,
“Oh, he loved Adidas.
That was part of my problem.
He loved the Adidas stripes, he loved them.
Well, when you really love something, try
to get somebody to look over here at something
different.”
Davidson doodled for nearly three weeks, estimating
she worked well over the 17.5 hours often
touted, to come up with the logo.
Her process was to draw “a picture of a
shoe and then I drew (logos) on tissue.
I’d lay it over.
And then I’d [crumple it up] because it
has to look good on a shoe.”
Finally, with a deadline looming, Davidson
presented five or six designs for Knight,
Jeff Johnson (who would later suggest the
name “Nike” for the brand), and Bob Woodell
to look over.
(She can’t remember the exact number of
logos she presented, nor does anyone remember
the exact date it was created.)
Knight’s response was underwhelming.
The first design he looked at was the “swoosh”,
he passed it up and looked at the rest, than
came back to it and said the words every designer
longs to hear, “I don’t love it, but I
think it will grow on me.”
Somewhat disappointed at his reaction, Davidson
asked for time to perfect the design, but
Knight said no.
She then submitted her invoice of $35 (about
$195 today).
Some might think she was ripped off for the
work, considering the logo she created went
on to become one of the most well known in
the world.
However, Davidson didn’t see it this way
as she was happy with the wages at the time
and had agreed to make the logo for that amount,
so fair’s fair.
The fact that it became world famous was simply
a nice feather in her cap.
However, this is not the end of the tale.
For starters, after leaving Nike in 1975 (she
had been given a job there after graduating
from college in 1971) she went on to freelance,
and being the designer of the Nike logo certainly
helped her acquire clients over the years.
A more direct benefit happened in 1983, a
few years after the company went public.
Knight decided to honor Davidson for having
created the company’s logo and for her early
work with Nike, so invited her to lunch, which
actually turned out to be a surprise party
in her honor.
At the party, he gave her a gold ring that
had the swoosh on the top with a diamond in
it.
But this wasn’t the big payoff.
He also gave her, according to Davidson, 500
shares of the company.
So how much were 500 shares of Nike worth
at the time?
Around $8000 or about $18,000 today.
Quite a sum given Knight was not obligated
to give her anything, nor was there any pressure
to do so.
But this wasn’t the end of it.
Davidson never cashed out those 500 shares
of Nike stock.
Since that time, there have been four instances
where the stock has been split, meaning today
those 500 shares are now 8000 shares.
At the current stock price of a little over
$97 per share, the $8,000 gift of stock in
1983 is now worth about 3/4 of a million dollars.
Not too bad for producing something in a couple
weeks of part time work that is essentially
just a curvy checkmark.
Bonus Facts:
• “Nike” is the Greek goddess of victory,
strength, and speed, the daughter of Styx
and the Titan, Pallas.
• In the beginning of his shoe selling career,
Knight sent some samples of the Tiger brand
running shoe to his old track coach, Bill
Bowerman, to get his thoughts on the shoes
and perhaps get some of Bowerman’s students
to wear them.
Bowerman was impressed and asked to become
a partner in the new company, Blue Ribbon
Sports, which was officially founded on January
25, 1964.
They started out by buying 300 pairs of the
shoe and selling them out of Knights trunk.
They also began experimenting on the shoe,
to try to make improvements, with Bowerman’s
track team serving as the guinea pigs.
• Before Nike took off, jobs held by Knight
included an accountant at Coopers & Lybrand,
as well as Price Waterhouse, and then an assistant
professor at Portland State.